Oh
welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar laboratory
medicine beyond the Box value based
health care and diagnostic evidence it
is presented by dr. Elizabeth Marlowe
who is the global director of medical
affairs for microbiology at Roche
molecular systems and Johanna Sickler
mph MBA who is the director of medical
affairs for point-of-care at roche
molecular systems my name is Judy
O'Rourke and I will be your moderator
for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speakers will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits and now without further ado
please join me in welcoming dr.
Elizabeth Marlowe and Joanna Sickler I
will now turn the presentation over to
them
you
thank you Judy and I would like to thank
the organizers of this speaker series
for inviting us to join today so the
title of our talk is Laboratory Medicine
beyond the box I'm going to be speaking
on the first half talking about
value-based care as it relates to
Laboratory of Medicine and thinking
about where the laboratory fits into
this paradigm and Joanna is going to be
speaking more about how do we think
about generating the diagnostic evidence
that's required for value-based
healthcare
so at the end of its presentation
you should be able to recognize the
changing model of laboratory medicine
define value based care discuss the
challenges to leveraging laboratory data
and understand the skill set that's
going to be required for the
next-generation laboratory
now as we think about technology and we
think about how things are changing I
can't help but think about Blockbuster
and one might be thinking what does
Blockbuster stores have anything to do
with laboratory medicine but what's
pictured here is the last blockbuster
store in the world and this is in Bend
Oregon
and what's ironic about it is probably
about 15 years ago there were maybe 9000
stores around the world where anybody
could walk in and rent a video on any
given Friday night after a long week at
work and I recall doing this probably
about hmm maybe one years ago 15 years
ago with my husband and the owner of
that store coming up to my husband
saying that he was closing the store
because the way that home entertainment
was going to be delivered was changing
now fast forward 15 years later and we
see the last you know the last door that
survived these changes in technology and
that the way consumers expect that this
technology is delivered to them and I
actually have to appreciate the fact
that the last black buster actually has
a sense of humor too and they actually
have a Twitter account so as this one
says a lot of people don't know this but
we own a large portion of Netflix just
kidding our electricity just got shut
off now you say this in tongue-in-cheek
but really as we think about healthcare
and we think about where healthcare is
going there's a lot of similarities
between what happened to Blockbuster and
where we're going with healthcare
so as we think about that let's think
about how do we want to define
value-based care
the value-based care is defined as a
healthcare delivery model in which
providers including hospitals systems
and physicians are paid not paid based
on fee-for-service that they based on
patient health outcomes an undervalued
based care agreement providers are
rewarded for helping patients improve
their health reduce the effects and
incidence of chronic disease and live
healthier lives an evidence-based way
which is key to our talk today the value
in value-based healthcare is derived for
measuring health outcomes against the
cost of delivering those outcomes and
this is what's going to be very key as
we move forward and seeing healthcare
change
so what you're seeing in this slide is
really its life expectancy versus
healthcare expenditures from about 1970
to about 2015 and what you can see on
this slide is that the u.s. outspent
most developed countries and actually
some underdeveloped countries as well
and what we spend is not reflected in
the outcomes a life expectancy is
shorter than most other development
countries and then like many delet
developed one developing one and
actually I looked it up since this was
since in 2017 there there was additional
data and those costs have gone up to
over $10,000 annually per person there's
a lot of reasons for this one of them is
the lack of health care insurance for a
lot of people it also the
fee-for-service model in the u.s. we
could go into a lot of reasons but you
know at the end of the day it can't
sustain itself and we need to start to
go about doing things differently
and if we can't think about healthcare
expenditures and and where we're
spending our money what you see here is
is what are the healthcare expenditures
for laboratory laboratory healthcare
expenditures account for about two to
three cents of every health care dollar
that we spend and you have to ask
yourself how many more pennies can we be
squeezing out of that two to three cent
not a whole lot more there's there
somewhere between four and 13 billion
laboratories tests performed annually in
the US with the single largest volume
medical activity and it's estimated to
impact three-quarters of all medical
decisions so if we think about where
we're spending our money perhaps we need
to start thinking about that 98 cents as
opposed to squeezing more out of that
two to three cents
and if we start to think about the
shifting model of health care you have
to think about where the laboratory is
in its lifecycle for many people they're
so focused on lab consolidation cost
containment that they're not looking up
to see that really the lab is shifting
from a cost of intent service to
provider of medical value and this is
where we are seeing they shifted as we
knew from a value to value-based system
and with that but that value-based
system will be more innovation
now with the laboratory and innovation
our job is a lot has a lot to do with
introducing new technology but the
reality is is if you build it it's not
necessarily true that they will come
introducing new technology into how a
healthcare system is complex and I
always said in my laboratory that the
science was the easy part it was really
everything else that went around it that
that made it more difficult and we'll
get into this a little bit more as we
get into Joanna's talk but which often
slows the adoption of new technology is
the cop the cost of bring it on and
position comfort level in practice and
while you can sit down and estimate an
ROI on any technology you want to
introduce the true ROI requires a voice
from the laboratory because of many of
the complexities and we'll get into
these in a minute
so what does it take to have a winning
diagnostic solution and what does it
take to really truly push diagnostic
technologies forward especially in the
evolving reimbursement paradigm that
we're in well number one we have to
recognize that FDA approval is only the
first step towards water adoption and
the evidence that is required for payers
as well as administration we need to
maximize the data integration
opportunities that can be utilized
through the EMRs or electronic medical
records and that integration of data
really needs to support appropriate
diagnostic testing it is to have minimal
disruption to the clinical care workflow
and we really need automated safety nets
safety nets that can identify gaps in
care and support test interpretation and
that can further be converted to
reimbursement opportunities to generate
revenues and reduce cost for the system
and lastly we need to develop
evidence-based literature that truly
demonstrates mettle medical necessity
and outcomes
so let's just take a moment to take the
laboratory perspective
operational challenges are tough and
every time I show this slide in an
audience and I say who can feel the
squeeze every hand in the audience
usually goes up the laboratory is faced
with changing technology constant budget
cuts further reimbursement cuts thanks
to Pama a shrinking workforce the
average age of a CLS in the u.s. is
somewhere in the mid-50s and we have
about a 60% shortage of laboratory
scientists going into the field annually
we there's a worldwide shortage of
pathologists people don't talk about
that a lot in fact in the UK there was a
recent publication talking about how
there were delays in cancer treatments
because of the shortage of histah
pathologists there's legislation that is
mandating certain testing and at the
same time the lab has to respond to all
this and continue to improve patient
care
so as we think about this let's just
take a simple look at one example of an
order and we're going to talk about
blood cultures the Holy Grail everybody
wants to improve sepsis diagnosis let's
just look at what it takes to work up a
blood culture part of the most important
specimens that comes into the
microbiology laboratory and normally you
would order three sets of blood cultures
over about a 24-hour period so two blood
culture bottles come in that's one order
as a set that blood culture bottle gets
put into the instrument the blood
culture instrument to get red usually
within about 12 to 24 hours
that's what culture would go positive
it's true positive and you get a Gram
stain that Gram stain would then be
called to the floor in a timely manner
and there's new technology that once you
have a Gram stain and that blood culture
goes bottle the bottle goes positive you
can run things like the bio fire or the
gen mark accelerate now has technology
and and it's an add-on test to
traditional culture workup that would
further require identification and
susceptibility testing
you
what you see here is an example of some
of the reporting that is seen by a
physician as as these test results come
out and what you have to appreciate is
that for the physician on the end who's
waiting for the results to manage their
patient they actually the blood culture
the the Gram stain would be called
immediately in a very timely manner but
from there the physician has to follow
up on that result and they have to go in
when they're managing the patient one by
one into the test results in the
electronic medical record and so you can
see here you have that initial Gram
stain result it says that the DCI D was
performed it was in e.coli and that
susceptibility is pending and this is
pretty complex and this is just for one
test order so if we think about this and
we think about introducing new
technology and introducing in some cases
technology that's an add-on there's a
lot more to this and we'll explore this
as we go through our talk in the next
hour
clearly there's limitations beyond just
lab operation costing out a test and the
analytical analysis you know oftentimes
there's a lack of published clinical
impact studies and we reintroduce it we
often assume that these results are
reliable providers will trust those
results and know what to do with those
results but really often times they'll
they'll monitor those results and their
comfort level comes with experience so
just because you have a result it
doesn't always mean it's actionable and
it will equate to improved outcomes
you talk about outcome
there's a few things that we can we can
do to define it
there's laboratory outcomes that would
include appropriate test utilization
reducing laboratory cost improving
productivity better turnaround time
quality there's clinical results such as
reduced antibiotic use decreased length
of stay morbidity and mortality
readmissions and the overall cost to the
healthcare system those we're measuring
outcomes we need to make sure that we're
all using the same ruler across studies
and what's really going to be getting
the attention of it as administrators or
the c-suite is that overall cost to the
healthcare system
the way you see here on this slide is an
example of some work that was done in my
former institution and this was a study
that was presented in 2011 and in my lab
we had been an early adopter of PNA fish
technology which is a probe based
technology for probing positive blood
cultures and we were being asked by our
administration about six years after
adopting it given the cost of adding
this technology what kind of outcomes we
were seeing what kind of bang were we
getting for our buck so what you're
seeing here is about 200 the results of
about 262 chart reviews that were done
based on some PNA fish results and this
was done by our ID physicians and you
can see that it was scored it was scored
a zero if treatment could have been
altered by the technology but it wasn't
so they want inappropriate therapy
it was scored a 1 if treatment was not
altered so they were on appropriate
therapy it was scored a 2 if the patient
was discharged or transferred it was
scored a 3 if treatment decisions should
have been altered but wasn't so there
was an education gap and it was scored a
4 if treatment was guided with the help
of that technology what you can see from
this result is less than 14 percent of
the time did we actually impact the
utility of that PNA fish and so what it
demonstrates is that you know the test
wasn't necessarily being attended at its
maximum utility if we fast forward to
2018 this paper was published looking at
the bio fire blood culture ID system and
where they actually looked at 6 months
prior and six months after
implementation of the technology and
they looked at outcomes not only lab
outcomes time to first identification
but they also looked at antibiotic
escalation de-escalation length of stay
discharged and what they found
Wow they significantly reduced the time
to ID they did not reduce any time to
appropriate antibiotic escalation the
escalation or length this day so we
still have a ways to go and I'm going to
let you know when I get more into this
as we talk about introducing technology
and evidence-based medicine
but with that I think we need to talk
about data because for me the lab is
just a rich sort of data and how do you
manage that information flow and where
are the value opportunities
so as we shift from this value or volume
to value based world this is what it
feels like for most devotional we're
dealing with data it's just coming at us
and we're drinking from the fire hydrant
and how do we expect for providers
managing patient to be managing the data
that's coming from them especially as
wishing Diagnostics get better more
precise but more complex and this is
where I think the lab has a huge
opportunity as as a member of the care
team
what I like to think of the laboratory
really is not as a service but really as
the data command center this is a
picture of the CDC data control center
and really they say service as an early
warning system and response network when
it comes to outbreaks the laboratory has
this it basically has the same task
within a healthcare system and I think
we have an opportunity here to function
in a data-driven world and provide more
value as we leverage that data
the problem with data and dealing with
data is there are gaps that we have to
manage number one data is dirty if
you've ever tried to do an outcome study
you know how difficult it can be to
access that data and once you do that
access that data is is make sure that
data is valid and while there's a lot of
very smart people out data scientists
out there you know we really do need the
right experts who can ensure the
accuracy and application of the data
that we're trying to utilize
there's been a call for analytical
frameworks so that we can actually have
a system to get into this data but we
need analytical frameworks that are
trends that allows the transferrable
solutions across systems it needs to be
generalizable and we need analytical
outcomes for actionable usability we
need information that can be provided
that provides actionable information and
this can come in a variety of forms be
it providing clinical decision support
for it earlier diagnosis personalized
intervention through laboratory
interpretation population risk
stratification improve disease
monitoring and we needed ability to
document the impact of these diagnostic
interventions on outcomes
when we think about Diagnostics in the
role of data analytics and information
this is what it looks like today in
terms of an antibiotic stewardship it
typically doesn't happen until after a
test result has been ordered and and
reported
but really what we need is we mean that
we need to recognize that diagnostic
stewardship is part of antibiotic
stewardship and it should be happening
before and a bad extrude ship so that
the lab has an opportunity to fill gaps
and care guide clinical decisions
through consultation and improve
reimbursement and ultimately improve
care
I think what's encouraging is there are
digital solutions that we're really in
the early senses but we're seeing
digital solutions and AI are ready in
laboratory medicine and there are pilots
that have been published on on that are
occurring in certain systems looking at
providing risk scores for things like a
septic patient or infection control
assignment and this perhaps the patient
is at higher risk for developing c-diff
there are analytical steps in terms of
workouts and where digital solutions are
playing a role in pathology its whole
slide imaging in microbiology as you can
see pictured here there's microbiology
plate screening and reading algorithms
for sorting and working up these
cultures we need to do a better job in
more thoughtful way of thinking about
improving our reporting and how we can
integrate some of these digital
solutions together but I think it's on
its way and we're going to see a greater
impact on that patient care
and as we're moving through this and we
think about what kind of skill set we
need for the next generation laboratory
leader to manage all of this
we also need to be thinking about
alternative delivery strategies to
healthcare
because the reality is is that health
the way that healthcare is being
delivered is changing it's moving away
from the old brick-and-mortar model of
care where you go see a physician office
or go to a medical center really we're
seeing integrated systems that can be
provided in a lot of different settings
there's dr. on-demand which essentially
elects you to FaceTime a doctor for your
phone my husband's a few huge fan of it
there's remote diagnostics I'm in my
former institution we used to send out
bit test for colorectal screening to our
members and we had a very high success
rate and we saw at least we saw a lot of
change coverage in those patients and
where we were seeing you actually there
was data showing that they caught
disease earlier and people survived
longer if they did catch disease there
are companies that have remote
diagnostics associated with STI
screening that's all done via the
internet and if we think about the way
this is transforming really I think we
should be looking to how retail is
transforming because there's a lot we
can learn
where will the laboratory sit in this
evolving landscape I'm going to do
analytical really well in the laboratory
the places where we really need need to
be thinking about things is pre
analytical and post analytical what will
specimen collection look like do we need
to have special kind of devices are
there population screening versus
diagnosis strategies that we need to be
thinking about will testing be done in a
centralized model or a decentralized
model and who will be providing that
oversight and how will the laboratory be
able to continue to provide that
oversight post analytically how will we
be reporting results how will be
ensuring that there's no patients loss
to follow up what will reimbursement
look like and what quality metrics will
be will we be incorporating given these
new models well it's a lot to think
about
I think it's just important to
understand that the laboratory director
of the future needs to be considering
this value and thinking about how they
can prove intent ori testing will
continue to grow
so with that I would I know there was
another talk in this fit series
regarding clinical lab 2.0 but if you're
interested in learning more I would
encourage you to go their website it
really is a grassroots effort looking at
the future of value-based care and the
placement of diagnostic services in the
American healthcare system and they're
very motivated group and they've got a
lot of great ideas and you may want to
learn more about them if you haven't
already
and if you're interested in hearing more
about my thoughts about the
next-generation laboratory leader and a
skill set that we're going to need I
have a recent editorial that I wrote
looking I'm talking about the lab
elaborate Orion in post technology world
and I have the website there for the
clinical microbiology newsletter if
you're interested
and with that in summary
laboratory medicine is shifting its
shifting away from a consolidated cost
contained environment towards really
being a provider of medical value and
while technology is certainly a part of
the solution it's not the only solution
and introducing technology alone is not
going to improve outcomes with that you
need the next-generation laboratory
leader who's really positioning the
laboratory no longer to be viewed as a
commodity or a service but rather as a
strategic asset where they have a
tactical role of data center so we can
really optimize care and reduce cost you
do need an analytical framework we'll
allow for standardized metrics and this
will allow us to capture and assess both
impact and support resources
and with that the next generation
leaders in the laboratory will need the
right skill set that will allow them to
be that champion that allows us to
leverage that laboratory data for
improved medical value and with that I
thank you for your attention and I'm
going to hand it off to my co-presenter
joanna stickler
thank you back and I'd also like to
thank lab roots for the invitation to
speak in this series Beth gave us a
great strategic picture of how to
leverage the value of the laboratory
what I'm going to focus on is more
getting into the nuts and bolts of the
evidence and what the actual evidence is
that's needed in order to show that
value by the end of this presentation
you should be able to define the
different types of diagnostic evidence
and common endpoints in order to show
the value of the lab and understand what
the drivers are of the shifting evidence
landscape what you'll see as I go
through this presentation is that the
bar continues to be raised on the level
of evidence that's really required to
show value and I want to walk through
some of the reasons why this has
happened first I think it's important
that we recognize that tools are not
always used as intended and this is a
lesson in the healthcare space that has
been seen time and time again by payers
and time and time again by healthcare
institutions and this has been a key
driver of why the evidence bar is
shifting just because something may make
something happen time and time again
they've seen that new Diagnostics aren't
necessarily having the impact that's
been projected so first let's really get
into that evidence and the different
levels of evidence that are required to
show value from the industry perspective
we really used to think about the world
10 years 15 years ago as ending at FDA
approval our role was to develop an
assay and go through the regulatory
process after that it would slot into
the lab and our work was done however
more and more we've come to realize that
the evidence required for regulatory
approval isn't enough the bar keeps
being raised and we need to be
developing more and more types of
evidence
you
so let's start with the basic so the
first level of diagnostic evidence is
clinical validity this is sort of the
classic evidence package that the FDA
requires for regulatory approval in the
US can the test correctly identify the
biomarker or the disease that isn't
intended to detect typically endpoints
include sensitivity and specificity
positive predictive value and negative
predictive value this is the first level
and I would say sort of the bread and
butter of evidence development for
Diagnostics when we think about how the
world used to be and how again from an
industry perspective we used to perceive
it is our goal was to improve these
metrics we want to develop a test that
is more sensitive and specific than the
test that was there before here's an
example thinking about influent
point-of-care influenza test over time
new technologies have been introduced
that has improved the sensitivity of
point of care detection today molecular
point-of-care tests are available that
bring that sensitivity to being on par
with routine laboratory centralized
Diagnostics so what we've seen is the
sensitivity go up but what this also has
resulted in is that the cost of a
point-of-care test has gone up and the
question were asked time and time again
is what is that value of that improved
sensitivity is it worth the extra cost
it is what we had before good enough and
that question of good enough and really
showing why a more sensitive test or a
quote-unquote better test and adding
value to the healthcare system is the
challenge that we're continually faced
with and that brings us to our next
level of diagnostic evidence clinical
utility and impact so how does
introducing a better a more sensitive or
perhaps a more specific test actually
improve the management of patients that
could look at issues like the
distribution of antimicrobial therapy it
could impact what types of additional
tests have to be ordered and we more and
more need to really think about that
right what is this test going to be
doing to change
how physicians are going to manage their
patients so a really important step in
thinking about evidence development is
generally to have a hypothesis to have a
belief in how we think a diagnostic will
actually change management and I want to
be clear that this is the really
important next step right is to think
about what we think could happen and
developing this evidence is a key piece
of the pyramid and this is something
that I do again and again in my clinical
study program however this is a step it
isn't the final destination and more and
more what we see is that words like if
had and could aren't going to get us to
the evidence level we need to be at why
is that well it comes back to what best
mentioned and what I mentioned earlier
as well this assumes that clinicians are
going to follow the results and of the
test and behave exactly as we
theoretically intent and I think we know
that in any system humans do not always
do that as a result that brings us to
our next level which is impact on
clinical practice in the real world so
in the real world when a test is
implemented how is it actually used and
is it used in the way it was intended
and therefore are the results that could
happen actually happening as I mentioned
before tools are not always used as
intended
so best mention the example of a bio
fire test for a bloodstream infection
and this is also from that same study
where in one clinical setting what they
found was that they weren't seeing the
practical match the theoretical well in
theory information of implementation of
this test should have chained clinician
prescribing behavior in their actual
institution they didn't see it and
something we need to take a step back
and think about when we implement new
diagnostic tests are what are the stakes
and what will truly be required to
change behavior when you think about
doing something like implementing a more
sort of strep a test for pharyngitis and
a primary care setting I would argue the
stakes are relatively low asking us in
this position to look at a test result
and make a determination about whether
or not should prescribe an antibiotic if
they end up making a incorrect decision
the consequence is most likely that that
patient will come back and they will
change treatments looking at something
like bloodstream infections we are on
the complete opposite end of the
spectrum the stakes in some ways
couldn't be higher
a clinician is worried about making the
wrong decision a clinician is worried
that if they prescribe the wrong therapy
or change therapy at the wrong time
point but this could have incredibly
serious consequences for the morbidity
and mortality of their patients as a
result we need to recognize that just
implementing the technology is
oftentimes not going to be enough we
also have to be thinking about the
overall systems and processes that are
going to be in place to support
clinicians and an institution to best
use these new technologies and that
brings us to sort of our final step in
the pyramid which is where we wish we
could always get to which is clinical
outcomes right how does implementation
of a new technology influence things
like mortality morbidity Hospital length
of stay the reality is is oftentimes
incredibly challenging to develop
evidence to demonstrate these types of
outcomes best mention that in the real
world data is very dirty and it's
oftentimes very difficult to look back
other times for certain types of
conditions it can be challenging to find
a large enough patient population to
actually show a statistically
significant result practically in the
world we live in today getting to
showing real rules and passed on
clinical practice is oftentimes going to
be a bar that's high enough but that
doesn't mean we shouldn't continually
strive to show the clinical outcomes and
a positive impact on patients from an
outcomes perspective when we implement
new technologies those one of the
classic examples when we talk about
outcomes
is genomic health and the implementation
of the Oncotype DX test this is a
company that's known for sort of having
done everything right in terms of really
developing an evidence package to show
that the utilization of their tests was
changing patient care however one of the
things that's interesting about what I
would say has typically been thought of
sort of as the classic way to do things
right story is more recently we've had
some new evidence come out that is
indicating that in some populations and
in the real world they aren't still
seeing those results and I bring up this
point just to make the ultimate point
that this is really hard it's one thing
to look at a theoretical evidence
pyramid it's important to understand
these different levels of evidence but
it's also important to recognize that
it's challenging it's challenging to
discern the difference between what's
going to happen in the real world and in
a research setting and it's challenging
to generalize results across different
populations to summarize all of these
pieces of evidence are important and I
want to declare that this isn't to say
that clinical validity doesn't need to
happen all of these things need to
happen but we need to recognize that we
need to be continually striving to
improve how we develop diagnostic
evidence and how we demonstrate that the
Diagnostics we're implementing are truly
having an impact on patient care now I'm
going to switch gears to talk about
another aspect of the nuts and bolts of
how we actually do this which is to
understand our stakeholders there are a
lot of different stakeholders when we
think about the healthcare system it was
in the Health System you have the clinic
labs the clinicians the hospital c-suite
and the patients oftentimes when looking
at the world from the health system
perspective you don't necessarily see
all the external stakeholders who were
also in play and important to consider
you have industry who's actually
developing these diagnostic tests you
have employers that's providing health
insurance you have government policies
and you have payers who are increasingly
based on their decisions about what
they're going to cover influencing what
is happening in our healthcare system
what's critical is to rest
that all of these stakeholders are in
play and for any given situation you
really have to map and think about how
the specific situation affects those
stakeholders when we think about
adoption of new diagnostic solutions
it's also important to recognize the
role that the money plays and as much as
we don't like to think it's all about
the money oftentimes decisions do follow
a lot of financial factors a key point I
want to make here is that while all of
this evidence I've reviewed is very
important different evidence really
speaks to different stakeholders and
different types of value so when we
think about payers payers are really
concerned about the cost of care
reimbursed providers so how much are
they actually paying to providers to
provide healthcare and how does that
impact the total amount paid to the
healthcare system
the mask is going to be different for a
healthcare system a health care system
is really thinking about how much are
they being green burst by payers - the
cost because that's going to equal their
revenue and so how does this impact the
cost of providing care to the patient I
bring this up because often times I see
a lack of understanding about the fact
that this math is different and you
really need to consider when you're
thinking about evidence who you're
speaking to and what the different
pieces of relevance are going to be for
them payers and the healthcare system we
have to recognize is a constant sort of
interface it's going to vary depending
on the given situation so you have to
customize your strategy and your
thinking depending on what you're
thinking about in that given situation
it's not going to be a one-size-fits-all
solution if we're thinking about
implementing a test is going to fit
under a DRG payment that's potentially
going to be very different than thinking
about tests that's primarily going to be
used in an outpatient setting for CPT
codes and it's really critical to map
that entire landscape when considering
the best approach as we come to the end
of this I also wanted to make the point
that you know the best put together this
really great vision for thinking about
how the laboratory can be a strategic
asset but many health care systems still
need to evolve in order to be able to
fully realize this true potential this
is a this is a comic strip about the
implementation of PCR at the point of
care for respiratory viruses and in the
discussion that these two lovely figures
are having isn't thinking about the flow
of the dollars and how they really
demonstrate value um the first book
little man here says let's see capital
expense consumable service contract
what's this I'm figuring about how much
it would cost to do point-of-care PCR
for respiratory viruses sigh it's a big
increase in the lab budget so the other
one has to I do it early results could
lead to improvements in patient care and
overall healthcare savings that's a
great thing however the administration
says the lab cost has to be offset by
budget cuts healthcare savings are hard
to measure and may not be in the silo of
the lab budget pill it to the kid with
the cost so it's a really great
illustration of the fact that we still
sometimes struggle with the way that
healthcare systems are set up and
they're set up in a very siloed way and
within those silos oftentimes an
increase in the lab budget from
implementing a better test even though
it's resulting in savings somewhere else
in the healthcare system it can be very
difficult to have that conversation and
I think that that's really the best
point as we evolved into this new future
I think we're going to see more and more
health systems evolve to be able to have
this conversation at the same time it's
really important to recognize that not
all health systems are there today so in
order to really drive these types of
changes you really need to understand
your stakeholders and you also really
need to understand their pressure points
for example within the healthcare system
you can sometimes think about a payer as
if a payer can get engaged with a
project you want to do and if a pair
believes it can have value that can help
to put pressure on an overall healthcare
system to want to drive that change as
well so in summary the evidence required
to achieve regulatory approval is step
one it's not our final destination and
we still have a long way to do go how a
test could change clinical care if
theoretically utilized in a certain way
is no longer compelling to support value
we have to be demonstrating clinical
evidence value in the real world and we
oftentimes need to be demonstrating it
again and again to show the constant
value lastly implementation is really
hard implementation is sort of the dirty
work right that it's not it's not as fun
to go through the Nitty Gritty of
figuring out how to actually make
something work in a real-world setting
but if you're going to do it
successfully
you really have to understand the
different stakeholders their interests
what motivates them and you also really
need to understand the specific
situation you cannot have a
one-size-fits-all solution what worked
one time and implementation might not
work in another part of your institution
because it's a different set of
stakeholders we're going to think about
things in a different way and with that
I'd like to take lab I'd like to thank
lab roots for the opportunity to give
this presentation thank you thank you to
dr. Elizabeth Marlowe
and Joanna Sickler for your informative
presentations I would also like to thank
leverets for making today's educational
webcast possible as a final reminder our
speakers will follow up with any
questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we'll see you next time goodbye